part of your career was writing songs
for other people before you decided that
you could record these songs yourself
you did uh Katy Perry you did uh Adam
Levine some Maroon 5. was it frustrating
to you to hear Maroon 5 record your song
no because it was never meant to be for
me I I wrote
um this song called stay by Justin
Bieber and kid Leroy goes I do the same
thing
it was a big song On Pop radio and it
has the DNA musically of me interwoven
through it but Leroy wrote that hook and
it was just never meant to be for me so
I never with all the songs that I write
if they're not meant to be for me it
just is what it is when Justin Bieber
and kid Leroy do stay I went and watched
the video of that and it's got like two
billion hits all these kids underneath
the writing this is the most beautiful
song ever I can't believe how great
Justin Bieber and kid Leroy are blah
blah blah blah blah blah that would
frustrate the [ __ ] out of me if I was
the guy who wrote it for whatever reason
it just and I mean this genuinely it
just it doesn't I I will listen to that
song
um in my car and be like wow I love the
drums that I did on this record and I'm
so happy for the success that these two
have had with this song and honestly the
song is so hard to sing live I'm almost
glad I don't I don't sing it but maybe
maybe I'll do a cover of it or something
but I I just I love the fact that I was
behind the scenes on that one there's a
lot of ins like there's a record an r b
record I wrote called slow motion for
Trey songs that I made in 2015 and you'd
never guess that I wrote and produced
that record because I'm a pop guy but
they played in like strip clubs and I
just I I love being behind the curtain
as much as in front of the curtain
really God what is that so play play a
little of that song what was that song
you wrote so it was really easy uh uh a
really easy hook slow motion
foreign
[Music]
thing about that song is that it was in
double time in the verse and then
and then when half time AKA slow slow
motion
maybe we could take our time there's
just a it's theatrical in a way sure
maybe I'll do a cover of that one day or
included in my set with yon but I just
love again that I had something to do
with that all of it to do